oh the bffs has got lots of pets in the  wall  and we've had an amazing week  celebrating pet adoption  it has been an honor to showcase rescue  pets with the aspca  and shelters across the country and to  close out the week i want you to meet  rocky  she's in new york should he shoot an 11  year old she's a very vocal kitty  ready to ease into a mature environment  rocky has been with the aspca for a  while and has  thrived as a foster cat  oh my gosh i love animals so much they  bring  so much joy and peace and happiness to  your home  it has been a really wonderful week and  i'm so happy that we could share this  time together  thank you everyone for joining us take  all of this into your weekend with you  we're so happy  to hang out with you thank you  you